in previous episodes in this series we
have begun exploring the fascinating
world of the islamicut occult Sciences
we have been given an introduction to
the topic we have explored the World of
talismanic Magic we have looked into
astrology in the early Islamic world and
we will eventually also dive into books
like the famous
Hakim or the pikatrix and its Latin
title but the most famous or should I
say Infamous book of occult Sciences in
the history of the Islamic and
arabic-speaking world is probably the
mysterious work entitled The shamsalm
Arif or the son of knowledge a book that
is revered by some as a useful book for
Spiritual practices and esotericism but
by others it is feared as the most
dangerous book in the world a cursed
book that just owning a copy of this
book will bring on evil forces or gin
that will mess up your life
so what is this book who wrote it and
what kind of things do we find in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
is probably the most famous occult book
in all of the Arab and Islamic world it
is a big text and indeed it is a kind of
Encyclopedia of all kinds of occult
practices that have been common in the
Islamic World historically
it covers everything from talismans and
amulets to how to construct them
theories of the science of Arabic
letters and their magical powers magic
squares how to summon Jinn and much else
the book is attributed to the 13th
century figure Ahmed al-buni often
popularly described as a magician and as
the source for much of these Sciences
but when we explore this figure and the
history of the text itself we find that
things are a bit different from how they
are usually portrayed little is known
about Ahmed al-buni's life his full name
seems to have been Abu Abbas Ahmad IBN
Ali IBN Yusuf Al Qureshi al-buni and he
probably lived from the late 12th
century to the mid 13th although his
year death is disputed as we will see
the name or nispah al-buni suggests that
he originated from the city Buna which
is in modern-day Algeria and the sources
we have indicate the same thing that he
came from and spent most of his life in
North Africa
he is primarily associated with Egypt
after all this places him in a very
interesting and significant time and
place he was a contemporary of the very
famous Sufi figure muhedin IBN Arabi and
came from roughly the same region indeed
al-buni was a Sufi and he was known
throughout his life primarily as a Sufi
teacher and not as anything like a
magician or something like that
furthermore in one of his writings
al-buni says that one of his own Sufi
sheikhs or Masters was Abdul azizawi who
led a Sufi Center in the city of Tunis
and who was also one of the primary
masters of IBN Arabi further connecting
the two figures this becomes even more
interesting as we find many similarities
between the teachings of IBN Arabi and
al-buni like the theories about the
science of letters and certain
cosmological and metaphysical principles
and this is important we should look at
Ahmad al-buni as a Sufi master who came
specifically from the heavily
speculative Sufi culture of the maghreb
which is Western North Africa and Al
andalus this region was ripe with Sufism
but it was a Sufism that was to
generalize more theoretical more
concerned with metaphysical and
cosmological speculation on top of these
spiritual practices and psychological
Transformations associated with Sufism
more so in the East you could say
this is an environment that brought
great Mystics with a speculative
philosophical quote-unquote band like
IBN Arabi IBN sabahin ibnbarajan and
indeed Ahmed al-buni himself and we do
in fact find many similar ideas in these
writers because importantly all sources
indicate that Ahmad al-buni later in his
life became seen particularly as a great
and revered Sufi teacher and master who
led a group of disciples or students
primarily in Cairo Egypt they would have
performed all the practices associated
with Sufism such as vicker remembrance
and khalwa spiritual Retreats and most
of albuni's writings attest to this very
strong Sufi connection and the fact that
he was a spiritual Master to several
students even after his death which is
sometimes said to have been in the year
1225 but other times we see the years 12
31 or 12 32 nonetheless after his death
his tomb became a place of pilgrimage
which show process the kind of status he
had as a Sufi teacher and that he was
maybe even seen as a kind of Saint or
Wali Ahmed al-buni also left behind
writings which have collectively come to
be called the Corpus bonionum by
academics and it is here that we find
those occults and esoteric aspects that
he has become so strongly associated
with
now most of albuni's writings are simply
books on Sufism similar to many other
books from that tradition talking about
these stages of the Sufi path practices
like the good and as well as the powers
of reciting the Divine names
even books that are more quote-unquote
occult or magical which do exist are all
essentially within a Sufi framework
specifically speculative Sufi Traditions
associated with the Islamic West as we
saw the problem with these writings at
least in relation to the subject of this
episode is that none of them are the
shams
at least not as we know it recent
scholarship by people like Noah Gardner
and John Charles colon have studied the
ibonian Corpus and its relationship with
the popular sham Salma Arif and suggests
that around five works attributed to
albuni can with some certainty be
considered to be his authentic work
these include works of a more
traditional Sufi nature such as the
element
a commentary on the names of God there
is
writings also include books that are
decidedly more occult and which deals
with topics that are associated with
things like esotericism and maybe even
that controversial word magic which of
course albuni himself would not have
used as a name for what he was doing
these are primarily the Lata if
the subtleties of the science on the
celestial letters and in the lead and
this is where it gets interesting a work
entitled the Sham Salman
that most famous book whose title
translates to something like the son of
knowledge and the subtleties of elevated
things more often known simply under the
shorter title
the son of knowledge
so Ahmed al-buni did write a book called
The Shamus and according to certain
medieval sources it seems that this
might have been his most famous and
widespread work
the problem is this is not the Shams
that we have today indeed they differ in
some dramatic ways actually the Shams as
we know it today and which is so famous
were Infamous around the world is a
large text that is often seen as a
cursed book as the most dangerous book
in the world and for those of you out
there that take that stuff seriously you
should know that I will be quoting from
this book in this video in an English
translation so not the original Arabic
but in an English translation it will be
pretty clear when I am quoting from it
but that's my warning to you so you can
either choose to just not watch the
video if you are legitimately concerned
about that or just sort of
keep a lookout for when I'm going to
court these these passages don't be
mistaken though albuni's is definitely a
work including descriptions of practical
occult Sciences indeed alboon himself
writes in the introduction that the book
contains and here I'm quoting quote
secrets of the wielding of occult powers
and the knowledge of hidden forces
so what is in this book well at the
center of Ahmad al-buni's
and really at the center of most of his
writings at least the occult writings is
the theories and speculation around what
is known as the science of letters
this is an idea that we find in many
medieval Mystics especially at this time
which theorizes that the Arabic letters
so the letters of the Arabic alphabet
have magical occult powers that can be
employed different letters are often
connected with certain cosmological or
metaphysical principles one letter might
be connected with the Throne of God the
arsh for example or with the planetary
spheres and since they have these
connections and especially since it is
these letters that make up the names of
God which have enormous powers in
themselves that can be used in various
ways for Spiritual practices or when
making talismans for instance IBN Arabi
who held very similar ideas even went so
far as to say that the entire universe
is essentially made up of letters and
words that God speaks in the Eternal
moment of creation so the Shams talks
about the science of letters and some of
the practical uses of these powers
the book also talks about Jinn the names
of Jinn who were captured by the prophet
Solomon it talks about angels and their
Natures as well as more practical
instructions on how to construct what is
known as alpha or cryptograms this is
essentially using letters and numbers to
create symbols that have certain powers
the most prominent example of this is
the so-called magic squares which are
well squares of numbers and different
rows that add up to the same number
regardless of which way you add the
numbers up they always add up to the
same number that's the principle and
even though albuni never uses words like
Talisman or amulet or that is the Arabic
equivalent of those words he essentially
gives us instructions on how to create
such objects using these cryptograms
letters Divine names and quranic verses
remember al-buni was a Sufi and theories
regarding these things appear to have
been rather common in esoteric Sufi
circles as we saw with IBN Arabic for
example and in certain circles of shiism
as well it wouldn't have been weird for
a Sufi Master at this time to be
involved with these kinds of things
especially in the Maghrib or North
Africa as we saw albuni and his
followers did not consider any of this
to be Ser or magic a word that has very
controversial and negative connotations
in the Islamic world even if there have
been nuances and different usages of
that word as we saw in previous episodes
but a Pious person like albuni would not
have seen himself as being involved with
quote-unquote magic
people have used other words like
rouhania spiritual work basically to
denote these illicit practices that to
us certainly appear magic adjacent but
which to them was obviously very
different
using the Divine powers of God to affect
things in the world is very different
from calling upon Jinn or forces other
than God nonetheless this was considered
esoteric stuff it was something that was
taught in Sufi circles but was certainly
not disclosed to the uninitiated if
anything that is what makes albuni and
his writings unique that he actually
wrote about this stuff stuff that really
only was taught orally from teacher to
student in a sort of initiatory context
but even then he makes it clear that
these writings are only meant for the
elite Sufi audience who can grasp its
meanings as he says in the introduction
and here I'm quoting again
quote
shame unto anyone who has this book of
mine in hand and reveals it to a
stranger divulging it to one who is not
worthy of it this was a book that was
clearly meant for his students and for
this spiritually Adept and not to be
spread to The Wider public so how did
Ahmed al-buni and the Shams get the
infamous reputation that they have today
and what about the modern shamsalm Arif
that we all know and love in the
Contemporary World well aside from being
a Sufi teacher or Master as we saw
albuni after his death did become known
as a kind of authority on occult
sciences and occult matters probably
because he wrote these books on these
topics which was relatively uncommon as
they would be spread orally most of the
time and and so because these writings
were attributed to albuni after his
death he did become seen as a kind of
authority on occult Sciences it doesn't
seem like this stuff was rejected or
seen as radically suspect by most people
or Scholars as his writings appear to
have been rather popular among a wide
array of people religious Scholars and
other figures associated with political
leadership and the aristocracy Mystics
and philosophers Etc they all read this
book and it was quite popular we see the
relationship between albuni and IBN
Arabi continuing in these contexts as it
seems like people would read The Works
of the two side by side
he was often thought that IBN Arabi
provided the theoretical and
metaphysical side of the science of
letters while al-buni's writings
provided the Practical descriptions on
how to actually use them we do have
critical voices like ibentamia and IBN
khaldoon who both lumped together IBN
Arabi and al-buni as quote-unquote
extremist sufis and equated things like
these signs of letters with seher or
magic in an attempt to Outlaw it and its
practitioners these two are perhaps the
most prominent critics of the popular
forms ever called Sciences in the Middle
Ages but even though these figures are
often upheld today as representatives of
Islamic civilization and its
intellectual tradition they did not
represent the majority at the time and
the writings of albuni continue to be
popular in various circles people
studied his Works wrote commentaries on
them and they developed a kind of
boonian occult tradition over the 14th
to 16th centuries and this is where we
get to the real sham
research has shown that the shamsalm
Arif as we know it today which is often
known as the
great son of knowledge the version that
is printed and spread around and
considered so dangerous first appears in
the 17th century and its contents are
radically different from the medieval
Shams al-madev actually traceable to
Ahmed al-buni himself
so what's going on here what is this
book The scholarly consensus today is
that even though it is attributed to
albuni the shamsubra is a compilation
created by one or multiple writers
around the early 17th century now the
book is based on albuni's writings for
sure indeed there seems to be a core
portion of the text that actually comes
directly from albuni's different occult
writings including of course the
original sham silma Arif but a large
part of the work probably the majority
of the work is from elsewhere probably
from later writings by figure in that
what we call the boonian tradition that
had developed over the centuries right
for example a lot maybe most of the
non-bunian parts of the Shams seem to be
from the figure abdulrahman al-bistami
one of the major commentators on
albuni's works and a famous occultist
himself so the modern sham Salman is
indeed a kind of encyclopedic work it is
a compilation of different writings from
various authors there is a core aspect
of the book that might be traceable to
Ahmed al-buni himself but a lot of it
perhaps the majority of it is
interpolations from later writers and it
is after all this modern text that is
the most famous it is this text that is
spread around printed in different
versions and that has this incredibly
Infamous reputation of being like the
most dangerous book in the world for
example and so for that reason is of
course this version of the book that
will be the main focus of our discussion
today so what is in the Shams El Cobra
it is a large text one that features
many chapters and sections dedicated to
all kinds of occult Sciences
it is often called a grimoire or a book
of magic and that label isn't entirely
wrong of course but calling it that also
neglects some of the core features of
the text
indeed most of it remains within a
strong speculative Sufi framework
the Shams had a complex and intricate
cosmology where everything is connected
to everything else a framework in which
all of these so-called magical aspects
figure now the book isn't always
terribly consistent in its ideas which
is one of the main reasons we can be
sure that it is a compilation but
nonetheless there is an intricate system
of threads where everything from the
Divine names the letters that make them
up the stars and Heavenly spheres the
human soul and every other aspect is a
part when you read the book you will
find sections about the powers of the
Arabic letters how the 28 letters of the
Arabic alphabet are connected to the 28
Mansions of the Moon as well as specific
planetary spheres
this is all connected to the four
elements the signs of the zodiac
different angels and much else it is
really esoteric stuff where as we've
said everything has a correspondence to
everything else numbers also play a
major role especially in the
construction of talismans and magical
objects instructions for which can be
found in the text especially in the form
of Gematria the common idea that each
letter of the alphabet corresponds to a
certain number so the letter alif
corresponds to one the letter ba
corresponds to two Gene corresponds to
three Dal corresponds to four and so on
and when you write out words using these
letters the word as a whole has a
numerical value too where the numbers of
the letters are added up which leads to
some really juicy esoteric stuff these
connections and correspondences become
Central when you are for example making
a Talisman these can take many forms but
often involve invocations or magic
square
so for example to harness the power of
Jupiter which has a kind of protective
and fortunate quality you can construct
a magic square so take the letter
associated with Jupiter Dal which has
the numerical value of 4. thus you make
a four by four magic square where the
numbers in any straight line add up to
the same number whichever direction you
count like I said before
then you write the letter itself Dal 35
times which is the numerical value of
the letter dull when written out as it
is pronounced using Dal alif and Lam
around the magic square you can also
write various names of God that include
that letter such as al-wadud in this
case the loving you then inscribe this
talismatic symbol when the moon is in a
good and fortunate mansion in the sky on
a parchment or an iron object or any
object really that you can carry with
you or that you can hang over your door
and similar things you can also write it
out with ink then wash off that ink with
water and drink the water
thus one has harnessed the fortunate
powers of Jupiter by using the intricate
thread of correspondences from the
sphere of Jupiter to the letter
associated with that sphere to the
numerical value of that letter to the
names of God that include that letter
and so on you see there is a connection
between all these different aspects as
well as the lunar Mansion connected to
these various things it's all connected
according to the Shams this can be used
for a spiritual benefit but also for
more worldly concerns it instructs on
how these things can be used to get
people to like you including getting
women to be attracted to you of course
to cure a fever or a scorpion sting and
even some of the more nefarious things
such as destroying your enemies although
the author also tends to discourage
people from doing these things saying
things like you know here is how you
destroy your enemy but just remember
that all these actions will be judged on
the day of judgment so he gives
instructions but also is like you
probably shouldn't be doing this stuff
for example then if you have have a
fever then do this again I'm quoting
here quote
if you write it then wash off the ink
with water and give the water to an ill
person to drink that person will be
protected from fever if you get stung by
a scorpion
quotes again
write them upon a piece of copper then
heat the copper in a fire this protects
against the scorpion sting this must be
written while the Moon is in Scorpio and
in an unfortunate astrological aspect
with Mars then after the seal has been
constructed dip it in water and drink
the water and even if your intentions
are less noble and you want personal
benefit
quotes
you may also write it in a piece of
yellow silk do this while the Moon is in
cancer it's domicile or else in the
house of Jupiter and secure from any
unfortunate aspects with Jupiter any
Pleasant smelling incense may be burned
if you do that and carry it with you you
shall accomplish all your goals and
attain what you want from Kings judges
and officials women will also love you
very important don't forget to report
there at the end
these are just some examples to show you
how this text works and describe these
practices if you want to invoke Saturn
rather which is associated with other
effects you do the same but instead with
the letter G which is a letter that is
associated with Saturn this letter has
the numerical value of three so in this
case you make a three by three magic
square you write the the letter G and
you write out the letter G with the
three letters or G ya and Meme and you
write letters or names of God using that
letter answering the whole process but
instead all the aspects have changed
because of the different correspondences
in the case of Saturn rather than
Jupiter the Sufi orientation of this
book becomes clearest when it discusses
the very strong powers of the Divine
names all the names of God have powers
and can be vocally recited or written
down to have different effects
the merciful has effects that correspond
to the attribute of Mercy as Salam The
Giver of Peace can be helpful to end
conflict and so on the name Allah is the
most powerful of the names since it
encompasses them all although there is
also talk about a secret greatest name
of God Ismail Azam a hidden name
supposedly composed of 73 letters that
is known only to the prophets
just knowing a few letters of this name
is said to give the person the ability
to perform Miracles and there's an
account of knowing this secret name that
figures like Jesus were able to raise
the dead I'm gonna quote here again
quote
through these names Jesus used to raise
the dead and cure the Blind and the
lepers these names are written in the
heavens
phrases can have similar effects
especially the phrase Bismillah
which has a whole chapter of the book
dedicated to its powers
this phrase which means in the name of
God the most merciful and compassionate
begins every Surah of the Quran except
for one and is recited by Muslims before
any major tasks such as holding a speech
for example this chapter on the
Bismillah explains that it is one of the
most powerful sentences in existence it
includes three names of God and is the
very first lion in the Quran the Shams
mentions a tradition where all of
reality is said to be contained in the
Quran the entire Quran in turn is
contained in the first chapter
the entire Al Fatiha is contained in the
opening sentence
and the entire Bismillah is contained in
the letter ba
even more so the entire ba is then
contained in the dots underneath the
letter
this dot thus contains the whole Quran
and metaphorically the whole universe
it is the point from which the entire
book of God is then written the point
from which the vast threads of the
universe are sown it is really
breathtaking stuff this phrase Bismillah
brings Lakwan just saying it but can
also be used as a kind of talisman
writing the phrase on an object or
washing it off with water and all these
things that we've already mentioned also
have these incredibly powerful occult
effects I'm quoting again quotes
was written across Adam's forehead 500
years before he was created
was inscribed on Moses's staff in Syriac
had it not been it would not have part
of the sea Bismillah
was inscribed on Jesus's tongue when he
spoke in the Cradle he used to speak it
when raising the Dead who sprung back to
life through the permission of God
Rahim was engraved upon Solomon's Ring
and for some more particular examples
quote
reciting it before sleeping 121 times
will draw down Divine protection God
will protect you from Satan theft and
sudden death all misfortunes shall be
averted
or quote if it the Bismillah is written
on a paper 101 times and buried on a
form the crops will be fruitful and will
be protected from pestilence and danger
as you can tell the book is pretty Pious
in a way it focuses primarily on God his
names the Quran and the letters that
make it up and everything in the book is
somehow connected to these very sort of
religious and Islamic themes of course
as we saw all of these things receive
esoteric interpretations and readings
all aspects have connections to some
Angelic concept or letter or planetary
sphere and that kind of thing even as we
get into topics that are a little more
dark you could say these themes remain
as they are the glue that really keeps
it all together throughout the book
after all the book does describe how one
can summon the good Jinn to do one's
bidding and this is done primarily
through using the Bismillah or quranic
verses to call upon these hidden forces
boonie if he is the author of these
sections cautions against doing these
things carelessly without proper
protection from God since one can for
example accidentally call upon an evil
gin or something as we saw in an earlier
episode about gem they can be both good
and evil they aren't exclusively evil as
some people may think and so all these
practices are aimed at summoning the
good gin through the power of God but
albuni also cautions that one must be
very careful with this because one can
perhaps accidentally call upon an evil
gin that would bring you Misfortune and
these kinds of things and so you need to
be very careful and protect yourself
against those kinds of things through
the protective power of God by saying
the Bismillah or writing the names of
God and all these kinds of things
there's really so much stuff that this
book contains that we can't go through
here it dives into the Ring of Solomon
the powerful ring given to this Islamic
Prophet that allowed him to control the
Jinn and many other impressive
miraculous Powers it talks about the
staff of Moses and all of the other
topics that one has come to expect from
the Islamic that are called tradition
you can kind of see why it has become
the most famous book of occult Sciences
in the history of the Islamic world as
it covers such a broad range of topics
it really any kind of Topic in the
occult sciences that you can think of
and does so pretty comprehensively while
also of course remaining firmly rooted
in the vocabulary and and cosmology of
Islam and the Quran this is indeed one
of those things that set the Shams apart
from that other most famous islamicult
book The Hakim or the pikatrix namely
that while the Raya or pikatrix is
primarily a text on astrology and astral
magic being based on theories and
traditions dedicated primarily to that
and from a scientific perspective the
Sham Salma Arif is more visibly based on
the Quran and on Sufi Concepts some
would even refer to it as more Pious or
outright Islamic even though these terms
are problematic of course so how come
this book has received such an Infamous
reputation today as we saw in most of
history with
a few exceptions like IBN tymia and IBN
khaldon the book wasn't necessarily seen
as problematic in any major way right
people studied it and and used it in
various ways so what's going on today
why is it that this book is so feared
and Infamous today a development that
seems to be one of the modern world that
has appeared in the last century or so
so what's going on here well there are
probably multiple answers to this
question in general we have seen a sort
of shift in the Islamic intellectual
world in the last century or two as well
as a shift in the general scientific
Paradigm of the world of course
we now live in a world that is much more
materialistic than the context in which
the book was written we have certain
ideals about what counts as
quote-unquote real rational science and
often deem anything else with terms like
superstition
the concept of magic has had an
especially rough time in this new
paradigm
and this has affected the Islamic world
too of course we saw in the 19th to 20th
century the rise of modernistic
movements within Islam that have since
become very influential one has tried to
emphasize the rationality of true Islam
and in that process rejected all aspects
of the tradition that is deemed
superstitious
it is this that has affected the role of
Sufism from being a majority form of
Islam basically to being relatively
marginal today Muslims have wanted to
distance themselves from Superstition to
counter arguments by orientalist
Scholars and thus the role of much of
these things in the Islamic world have
been increasingly looked down upon and
downplayed so this General trend is one
factor The Scholar lyanna seif has also
argued that during the 20th century
possibly connected to what we have said
there has been a quote de-esoterization
of albuni's writings that the Sham Selma
Arif and its contents have been stripped
of their connection to Sufi cosmologies
and metaphysics which as we saw earlier
is the brief framework and threat upon
which basically all aspects of the book
is based removing Sufism from the Shams
takes away all its connection with
spiritual and religious practice it
takes the complex and intricate
cosmology where everything fits together
and strips it of its essential core
grimoires and books of magic written by
controversial occultists in Egypt in the
20th century whose ideas became
connected and traced directly to albuni
and Shams also contributed to this
General trend for these reasons and
probably many others too the shamsalm
Arif has become something very
controversial today in the Islamic world
it is often seen as a book of pure black
magic a cursed book that will bring you
Misfortune a book that promotes devil
worship as I said in the beginning it is
often said that it is the most dangerous
book in existence on the other hand we
have other groups that have a
relationship with the book that is a bit
more kinner similar to how many in
history have studied this book seeing it
as a tool for Spiritual Development and
esoteric Sufi ideas but of course while
keeping a very strong emphasis on the
fact that it needs to be studied with a
proper teacher so that there can't be
any misunderstanding of what the book
teaches in other words it is a book that
evokes many different kinds of emotions
from different kinds of people
regardless it is clear that there is a
great interest in this book and an
increasing one it seems
recently the first English translation
of a significant chunk of the book was
made by Amina inlos and JM hamadi
published by revolor press which has
gained some attention and for good
reason it is also this translation that
I've relied on for the most part in this
episode it is clear that the occult
Sciences has been a prominent part of
the Islamic at World historically and in
many places still today remember that we
are using the word Islamic kit rather
than Islamic to avoid stating that these
things are part of the Islamic religion
per se it is up to Muslim Scholars and
theologians to make statements on the
normative status of the shamsalem Arif
and its contents in Islam but we can at
least be sure that these are ideas that
have been widespread and popular in
parts of the world dominated by the
religion of Islam it nuances our
understanding of History religion and
the Occult which is after all a good
thing and in understanding the history
of the occult Sciences there are few
texts as significant as the shams
and its author Ahmed al-buni or at least
it's attributed author Ahmed al-buni now
we hopefully have a better grasp of this
fascinating topic one of talisman's gin
and magical words all things fitting for
the spooky month of October
I'll see you next time
foreign